can i do a little can i do a little
freestyle
sure gonna do a little freestyle traffic
traffic
feeling kind of classic there's a ford
maverick huh
huh
thanks for listening guys we'll see you
on monday
well appreciate it it's friday it's
revenge of the sis
i was almost late it's almost late but
we weren't we we're here we're here
we're happy to be here
okay jesus christ
well good news royce that was actually
jamie kennedy
that did that bit not me so oh it's his
fault
so i'm supposed to feel better that you
copied a jamie kennedy bit
yeah that makes it worse you i'm sorry
it's important to me that you understand
that that makes it worse i'm sorry uh do
you have a problem with
transcendent comedy genius jamie kennedy
you know he's part of the kennedy family
a lot of people don't know that
i don't think that's true no it is it's
true he's he's actually
from the shriver side but he changed his
stage name to kennedy because of the
shriver family nobody cares about
is a bootlegger too you know it's a
common misconception that joseph kennedy
was a bootlegger when he's like
right in your [ __ ] though he
he was working on some stuff
to get alcohol into the us before it was
legal
but he didn't actually import any booze
he gobbled up a lot of licenses i'm
gonna ask you a question sure energy
answer me honestly you're pranking me
i'm not planking bro
you're not blanking me whoa it's not a
plank okay he's not really a bootlegger
he was a prank
all right did you draw this blah on me
oh god i'm so bad
i'm obsessed with the dover bro but you
know literally
some people [ __ ] hate not only hate
them
but hate that we cover them they hate
that we cover them
well because someone even commented like
it's beneath you
because there's everyone has a different
everyone has different
like things and quirks and stuff so
you're not we're not always going to
agree
there's things that you guys love that
we cover and we cover them i
[ __ ] despise them but when it comes
to the dober brothers i
i like i hate them too i feel where you
guys are coming from i hate them too
but there's just something so
embarrassing about them that i can't
stop watching
because it's like some of these other
people we cover they're like is it like
living filth and like there's just all
this awfulness sounds something
nightmare fuel but the dober brothers
really are just
i don't know there's just a certain
pathetic oh no the amazing thing about
pathetically
pathetic millionaires which is the
they're not millionaires stop why are
you yelling at me they're not
millionaires i'm on your side my parents
are missing they're on the same team
their parents are people at me
this this needs to stop they are
millionaires
their parents are millionaires i
guarantee you they're not worth millions
i they have to be right no
i'll bet you [ __ ] well now maybe with
the channel now with the channel now
they have to be millionaires they have
to be
yeah maybe but they have to but but
again when you're when you bought
the success with the parents money is it
really your success
like i think rob gavigan's a millionaire
is 100
you think he's a millionaire okay you
gotta make this money
money rob's so rich and cool can i
borrow some money right rob you're
you know i was just saying the other day
like probably a good looking dude man
you know
gonna get some money but it's not like
but those they're not
millionaires they're not successful
youtubers any more than hunter biden is
a successful oil executive
you know what i mean like it's not it's
just it's your dad
did a bunch of stuff and it was like oh
cool i guess i just have money
too by default no i don't know there's
no way to know no
people keep saying people have kept
telling us that the mom was some kind of
gymnast
i read that too yeah a few people she's
some kind of famous gymnast
yeah but then why is like that doesn't
make any sense either right because like
there are there are people that won like
gold medals
and they're doing like [ __ ] you know
that they're doing like uh
aarp commercials now so they don't have
a lot of money so why does this one
gymnast have a lot of money
unless she was a gymnast and then went
and like [ __ ]
dudes in dubai on boats or she could be
one of those gymnasts that was actually
an undercover like you know kgb spy
you think so yeah i don't know man i
don't know but watch a lot of movies
just so you just a lot of bond yeah
james blunt these are good movies
been watching american bond uh jason
bourne movies i always had a problem
with the bond movies you know why
because it's it's too many hot chicks
i'm with you well because all the scenes
where you get cindy's like hot
uh undercover chicks to like seduce him
and then kill him
all these female assassins when in
reality you know when you look at the
large
you know global situation when you're
gonna go kill james bond
yeah you're gonna send a guy yeah
because he would have succeeded
he'd send a guy with a sniper rifle he's
because the guys like the guy with the
sniper rifle in the hotel across the
street
in prague isn't gonna fall in love with
james bond he's just going to shoot him
through the window
and go and collect his paycheck um
so we could have wrapped up bond in one
film if we were there but i think they
want to make send a guy
and shoot him in the fights like the
scott evil thing yeah just shoot him in
the head right now we'll be done with it
well the new double 07 is a woman not
bond can we go back to can we go back to
idris elbano
not looking bad right now all of a
sudden it's not such a bad idea
see what happens when you guys [ __ ] we
don't want a black james bond well look
what happened
you should have just taken the black
james swan we should have taken black
james bar
happy with yourselves now idris elba
would have been the tits as james bond
yeah and not instead of having tits as
james bond well not only is the new dub
okay so here's what it is she's not the
new james bond she's the new double 07.
so they're going to kill
james bond hold on because they don't
want a black bond so the new double 07
is a woman but you know what all she is
she's a black woman
so you got see now so you ended up with
this is what all right look guys this is
a classic classic
uh lesson in negotiation right if you're
just gonna
burn everything and tell everyone to go
[ __ ] themselves and you're not gonna
compromise
what you end up with is nothing in most
business situations
they give you an out offer you give them
a counter offer and you guys work it out
but since you guys went no james bond's
white james bond's white james bond's
white james bonds white
now we don't get interest now we get a
black woman here's what it is
meanwhile big news out of hollywood
the next james bond film is getting its
first
black and female 007
and they cheer and they cheer like
[ __ ] seals what is this and they
cheer
like seals well to be fair and i'm sure
they don't know if it's good some of
them i'm sure might have clapped because
they're lefties or whatever
but let's not ignore the fact that
there's also a massive applause sign
and that you're basically you basically
have two production assistants on each
side of the audience
poking them with sticks and making sure
you're cheering loud enough so
is some of it genuine maybe but i think
a lot of that is just because the
sign went on